はーい
はいというわけでみなさんはシャボン玉あぁそんなことあっは皆さんシャボン玉で遊ん
だことありますでしょうか今日の第二僕はありとあらゆるシャボン玉をズームしました
おっきなシャボン玉作れるやつから朋友あの
シャボン玉今基本的なあノーマルシャボン玉とかヒロンなサポート目
茶筅日したんですよ話思ったんですよヘリウムだってこれまでもずっと高く
dm だってこれ声変わるだけじゃなくていくんですよね確か浮くうくれり字ガスで
膨らませた風船はスラーに飛びますしてことはシャボンなの縁会中津で膨らむと東部ん
じゃないかそんな気がしてならんのですよって雪は早速スロやっていこうと思います
たらどうやってやるかが問題ですねどうやっ
やる全然やり方も何も考えずここまで来てしまいました多分普通に行き退けかける
ところヘリウムカ所にしちゃえばいいのかなって気がしてましてゲッツーにやってみ
ましょうその飛ばないんですよ
[音楽]
まあ見てもらって分かる通り下にちゃん性をきれいねー
ダーレー完全やっぱり下に行きますね思いんでしたに入っちゃいます売ってるぞこれ
いくと思うんだけど忘れやなんだろうピって見てると思いますねいきます水2番
アーティスト今日しますいきます
パッハーパー4バックどう伝えればいいとこれ待ってカメラの画角を変えましょう
いけませんいます見ていることができます
ほれほれほれ
安全に出来ません猫だこれさでは強めに押したら
あ全部行っちゃうすごいすごいすごい
うんっこれ大きなサポーターもいけるんじゃないか説ありますから大きいさぼんな音
ですみましょう
ok が作れるけどやっぱり下に下がってきちゃいますね
全然というわけで変な感じでいいかやってみよそう
どうやってて縁を出すぶっかけながら探す使うしかないと鼻息ます
あっ日ちょちょっと入ってるんじゃいます
どうだ
うおっ
ん
無理だねでかいんださすがにやっぱ山荘まぢちゃんで無理っぽい流れ巨大なヘム
シャボン玉を作るのはたぶん無理ということが分かりました
うわまってもう雨じゃんい子どもたちが皆ここまではここまではをは袖をわさび俺が
本当にしたい事がこんなチンケなことにシャボン玉がテレビで行くことも分かったん
ですけどここからがこちら
触れるシャボン玉これどうでしょう触れるということはほぼがれないに等しい詰まるよ
すごいすごい
あ触れる触れるちゃんと触れますねまあ触れるんですけど結局落ちてきているという
ことですわじゃあはれ会社まだできるんですけどねもうちっちゃいのかなあんまり
大きくできなそう
うーんちょっとこれで海を作れるのでこれでこっちは一応割れないシャボン玉ですよね
それをまとめて入れてみます
ちょっいます
んビデオはれない巨大なシャボン玉
[音楽]
おっあっあぁああああ惜しいとこまで行くのに耐久力が足りんというのか
優しく
さあ
どうだどうだどうだどうだそうだルー
goo
ああもう無理な気がしてきたそもそもすんげー成功率が低いしできてでしょもうなんか
触ったら割れちゃうんですよあとなんか
見せるために鳥の糞みたいなの落ちてくるんでちょっと嫌ですね
お前ら俺子供で終わると思ったからここまでは子供の遊び俺はなくて25歳に考える
ことも自分が次エフェクトいるこちらもうなんかバブルボールですもうシャボン玉か
どうかもわかりません
そんな彼に減りいるんです打ち込めばおそらくもうもう
さえ全くのシャボン玉かなバベルボールって書いてあるからしたもんだまだでしょうね
もう空を飛び続ける伝説のバブルボールができると思ったわけですよなあと問題がどう
やってヘリウムガスをここに出るかですできます
[音楽]
んいますわーもうやだ音がヤバイ
まだで本当にただの分
web 造物
[音楽]
パーツ入りました
中身が全てヘリウムガスのバブルボールでさあ飛んだゲー
[音楽]
me
バッハ